can i start by thanking honourable
members from across the house for their
contributions today and i believe the
debate has demonstrated why this house's
voice had to be heard and why it was
right to recall parliament
we heard important speeches important
interventions on all sides expressing
deep concerns about the situation that
we can all see now in front of our eyes
unfolding in afghanistan
together we think of the sacrifices made
by so many of our armed forces to keep
us safe at home to lay the foundations
for hope and a better life for the
people of afghanistan and i know that
there are
many honorable members across the house
who have served in the armed forces
some in afghanistan and just how
important that our response to the
current crisis will be on all sides
mr speaker the
my right honourable friend the member
for maidenhead made a very powerful
contribution on the gains made in the
last 20 years in protecting and
supporting women and girls
the honourable member for ross sky and
lochberg made the case for arab and
the support that we give
to those and i hope that the scottish
government will help us with that
resettlement and i will take him up on
the overture that i think in good faith
he made
i also want to thank the
right honourable lady for campbell well
who i think spoke particularly
powerfully about the generation of women
and girls empowered by uk and western
intervention over the last 20 years
she's absolutely right that we must do
everything we can to safeguard those
games that were made
the my honourable friend the member for
bournemouth east made some important
points i think about the
over-centralized paradigm that had been
applied in afghanistan and that was
echoed by the honourable member for
birmingham perry barr
i think there was some agreement across
the site at the house about that my
honourable friend the member for
plymouth moore view gave us and gave
voice to the frustrations i know many
veterans will feel as we withdraw and he
also made the important point and i know
he was referring to ptsd and other
conditions the importance of dealing
with the mental health of our veterans
at what will be a very difficult time
for many of those i will give way
i thank my honorable friend for giving
way um i wonder if he would join me in
paying tribute to the many brave members
of our armed forces who've returned to
face the world after their service in
afghanistan with life-changing in
injuries um and if you would also join
me in thanking the staff past and
presence of the defence medical
rehabilitation center which is now based
in stamford hall in rushcliff
for the tireless work they've done to
help them
i thank my honourable friend we pay
tribute to all of those who've returned
and
paid the price through physical or
mental health injuries and of course
a huge tribute goes out to all of those
organizations who are supporting them
the the can i just make a little bit of
progress a little bit of progress and i
will come back to my uh to the
honourable gentleman i also thought the
honourable gentleman for barnsley
central spoke particularly pat i don't
know if he's back in the chamber but
spoke particularly uh powerfully about
the need for a concerted international
response and the right honourable lady
for hackney
north gave voice to her constituent
veteran jack cummings
and the sacrament the sacrifices that
were made by so many on the battlefield
my right honourable friend the member
for chingford uh also gave i think a
very powerful uh speech and made the
point that how we leave is
as important if not more important than
the question withdrawal itself and i can
tell him because he asked the specific
question that we tested very rigorously
the uh the approach uh with our u.s
allies when they consulted us
the right honourable lady for normanton
pontefract and castleford i think also
gave witness to the many terrified
afghans who now face the threats and the
risk that comes with taliban control
the right honourable my right-on-book i
give way to the honourable
i'm very grateful i've had lots of
constituents get in touch today to say
that the thing that they're most anxious
about and i think many members have
reflected this in the debate today
is those people who are terrified in
afghanistan today wanting to get out of
afghanistan many of them were wanting to
help get out of afghanistan but for some
reason we're saying it's twenty thousand
that will take over several years but
only five thousand this year if the
government could just simply say
whoever manages to get here this year we
will take this year i think that that
would be a significant advance
can i thank the normal gentleman i come
on to address that point but i
understand the point he he makes the my
right honourable friend the member for
uh north shropshire gave a courageous
speech i'm just going to make a little
bit of progress i think i've given way
so far and i will i i will do when i
come on to that point my right
honourable friend the
member for north shropshire gave i think
a truly courageous speech
i welcome his contribution and we
welcome him back to the chamber
my uh
honourable and noble friend the member
for um
basildon asked us about the application
of arab to the british council staff
and whether indeed it applies it does
apply and we are straining every sinew
to make sure it can
work and be applied to them as
effectively as possible and i'll come on
to to explain the practical arrangements
and challenges we've had around that
i'll make a little bit of progress uh
there were many other heartfelt
insightful and truly valuable
contributions in the house today
mr speaker i also listened very
carefully to the labour front bench and
uh the right honourable gentleman the
leader of the labour party made clear
his decision uh his support for the
decision to withdraw from afghanistan i
think that's clear
he listed a range of things he wants the
government to do quite rightly including
supporting the un efforts taking action
in the u.n security council support
through nato support for ordinary afghan
afghans
and and not allowing money aid to go to
the taliban we're doing all of those
things and rightly so
the right honourable gentleman did not
give a single example of an action he
would have taken
that we have not not won
but then issued a series of searing
criticisms the shadow foreign secretary
took a similar approach in her speech
and i'll come to address the various
points that she and he made
but i would i'll make a bit of progress
but i would pay uh welcome what she said
about our ambassador sivori bristow and
the team on the ground
in case there was any doubt the shadow
foreign minister the honourable member
for abrahavan said yesterday we are as
the labour party have no problem with
the american decision to withdraw troops
unquote
so the leader of the labour party agreed
to the decision to withdraw
but now with his predictable proclivity
for hindsight
[Music]
the right honourable gentleman
criticizes the consequences of a
decision that he backed
and he does so with no serious or
credible alternative of his own
not even a hint a reminder of
shakespeare's adage
the empty vessel makes the greatest
sound
[Music]
so mr speaker in any crisis
it is how you respond that is critical
as my right on law friend may and the
government has two overriding priorities
first we must evacuate our own people
the british nationals the dual nationals
in afghanistan who now want to leave
those who served our country so loyally
and allied to this we must live up to
the best traditions of this country in
playing our part in offering safe haven
to those afghans who are now fleeing
persecution from the taliban as refugees
[Applause]
i'm very grateful to the foreign
secretary given way and it's absolutely
right that the united kingdom makes this
generous offer to the people of uh
pakistan who need somewhere safe to come
but there is concern among my
constituents that we don't in being
generous and open open the door to those
who would wish to come here and do us
harm so can the foreign secretary uh
confirm that road bus checks will be in
place to ensure that no one who would
wish to do us harm will be able to get
uh through this route
thank you mr speaker my honorable friend
is absolutely right
of course we need to be open-hearted and
generous but if we were to allow people
to come to this country who subsequently
attacked this country we'd be back in
this house debating a very different set
of issues and therefore we need to
make sure we have some basic checks in
place also to make sure that the seats
on those planes go to those we want them
to go to
and i pay i'm going to make some
progress i've been very generous i'm
going to make some progress i want to
pay tribute to those leading this work
i've already mentioned so laurie bristow
our ambassador there's a phenomenal
cross-whitehall team of military
personnel i pay tribute to the defense
secretary home office officials i pay
tribute to the home secretary and
they're working hand-in-glove with
gunfire overhead to save others before
they get out themselves
and i want to pay tribute also to the
rapid deployment team that flew into
kabul last night to support that effort
and to the troops that went in to
protect them and secure the airport so
that we could prosecute this evacuation
effort
mr speaker we're training every sinew on
that evacuation effort and it is
supported by the crisis team in king
charles street with home office experts
military planners and they're working
around the clock and i pay tribute to
them having visited them yesterday i
give away to the honorable lady like
thank great very grateful for the
foreign secretary for giving away can i
specifically ask him about the arab
relocation program will he expand it not
just to cover the british council but
also those working for uk aid agencies
those working for uk contractors who
work for uk funded programs and who are
also in fear of their lives who are
hiding from the taliban being chased by
the taliban as we speak will he include
them in the relocation program as
members from all sides have called for
to happen
[Applause]
let me come on and address the totality
of the arrangements and then i think
that will answer squarely her point the
evacuation uh effort has three strands
and by the way it's been mr speaker in
place for four months first it's worth
recalling we advised all british
nationals to leave afghanistan back in
april and many hundreds did so on
commercial flights with the benefit of
consular support and advice from our
team
since the security situation
deteriorated last weekend we switched to
charter flights to get nationals out as
well as
those under the arab scheme the first
flight left kabul on sunday with around
150 uk nationals and their dependents on
board they've arrived back in this
country safe and sound in the last 24
hours 646 people have been evacuated a
combination of nationals afghans who
work for us and uk allies and there will
be eight flights following today
uh
the the the i'll make some more progress
because i've only got four minutes i've
already uh given way on a number of
occasions
the the crucial point was that in order
to secure the airport we had to
inject 600 british forces we had
thousands come in from the americans
without that we wouldn't be able to get
any of those to the airport indeed out
of them or process them in the way we
need to
the second strand of the evacuation
beyond british nationals is the arab
programme also set up by the defense
secretary back in april
to help those who work for us and who
now face the risk of retribution
precisely because of the loyalty that
they showed to our country
and to date mr speaker we've resettled
over 3
300 afghan staff and their families that
includes 2 000 since april the most
generous scheme of its kind offered
anywhere in the world and rightly so i
give way to the honourable gentleman i'm
most grateful to the foreign secretary
in giving where i thank him for all he's
doing the united kingdom led the way on
the friends of syria group before in
convening the international community on
bringing forward humanitarian package
will the united kingdom do the same with
afghanistan to get countries like the
uae jordan and kuwait who are also part
of the nato action in afghanistan
i thank my honourable friend his
absolute right to raise this i'm going
to come on to that point if he uh allows
me to
um the third strand of the evacuation
scheme uh is uh as my right honourable
friend the prime minister and the home
secretary announced today are planned to
provide a bespoke asylum offer to settle
20 thousand afghan refugees over over
five years
and like the home secretary herself let
me just say as the son of a refugee i am
deeply proud that this government is
continuing the big heart of tradition of
the british people in offering safe
haven to those fleeing persecution
so we're getting our nationals out those
that work for us out and we are
providing a lifeline to the most
vulnerable i can also tell the house
today that we have uh contacted all of
the achievement scholars in afghanistan
not just to tell them they can come but
to actively make arrangements for the
upcoming flights to the uk
[Music]
mr speaker
at a time of crisis we also need to look
to the longer term and there are four
areas that need particular focus counter
terrorism we must never again allow
afghanistan to be a haven for terrorists
we work very closely with all of our
partners within the parameters that the
current situation allows secondly the
international community must be prepared
to respond to the humanitarian plight
caused by the taliban's campaign
uk is already using our convening power
our aid budget to galvanize the global
response thirdly we must work to
safeguard regional stability and that
will require us to work with different
partners and require engagement with key
regional players including india china
russia pakistan central asian states
however difficult
or complex that may prove and outside of
our comfort zone and we will be fully
supporting the efforts of the secretary
general of the un special envoy for
afghanistan
or no
the fourth area is human rights and
accountability we will hold both through
our domestic sanctions regime but also
working with the indians who chair the
un sanctions regime for afghanistan uh
that to make sure we can exercise a
moderating influence on the taliban
regime we will pursue each of these
areas with vigor
as the prime minister
has already uh made clear we'll be
convening a special meeting of g7
leaders to consider a concerted and
coordinated response we will be looking
at the question of a contact group of
international partners on afghanistan
and we plan an event at the un general
assembly next month to focus minds and
raise funds for the humanitarian
response
we are raising our aid budget in
response